I've just thought Thor swag neuro and I
thought it was really good level that
you never gonna get back always push it
open to the brain never respect you
respect that retrieves the tteyuu
beachhead
[Music]
having never seen a Thor movie before I
kind of didn't know what to expect
coming into this you could say I
happened Thor Thor before it please
don't just like the video the movie
really sucks you in and it's great for
newcomers it's a really good popcorn
movie that's basically about Thor
travelling across the universe to stop
his home ask God do that joke about 10
times getting destroyed by his evil
sister no one's mentioned her before
she's shown up it's the evil sister
thing you know one of them I've got an
evil twin brother who by the looks of it
is the god of throwing swords because
that's all she does try the whole movie
and he has to team up with his best
mates to take her down the opening hours
a bit slow I didn't really know what
expected going off the trailers it
wasn't really anything like that so I
really wanted them to get through that
middle in the film really ramps up when
we get to the Thor Hulk fight and it's
hilarious and works really well and it's
just the right length and it's a really
good action-packed fight what I love
about the Thor fight is is a Thor loser
like so there's also some brilliant
cameos in the movie we'll get a great
one from spoiler alert
Benjamin Cumberland we'll also get a
great Stanley one spoiler on that one
Stanley's in the film Jeff Goldblum's
also really good in it he does are a
great Jeff Goldblum impression that was
a terrible actually see Jeff Goldblum or
as the villain as opposed to Heller the
Cate Blanchett character it's just he
fits more in with this movie where she
seems sort of alien to everything a lot
of the movies lowest points are when we
follow her and she goes on a crappy
little adventure with Karl Urban that no
one really cares about nice [ __ ]
you want to get to the 8u sci-fi stuff
another big problem that I have with the
movie is some of the jokes don't really
learn like model have sort of painted
themself into this corner where they
have like a really serious touching
moment and then someone bursts out with
a hilarious joke
add some levity but when you do know
every three minutes
it does your head in you know us humans
but complex characters sure we like a
laugh once in a while but we also like
to see severity of the situation knowing
that within our weaknesses that comes
strengths and we can be whoever we want
no matter what and I want to poop my
pants
that's basically what it is every five
minutes and it just kind of gets on your
nerves and it really doesn't take this
movies backed away and it turns it from
being what could have been quite a deep
an emotional film and it just your
standard popcorn movie I mean it is good
I don't miss like off but it couldn't be
elevated to such a higher point if they
had it just kept some of them emotion
within these moments still though it's a
great ride it certainly got me more
interested in what's gonna come
regarding in the future I do kind of
want to go back and watch the first two
which yet well done it's accomplished
its goal and getting me interested in
those films so what did you think of the
film have you bought it what what what
do you think let us know yet or I'll
knock you out or subscribe by clicking
my face somewhere appear somewhere
thanks for checking out my review and
I'll see you next time take care
poof